so Comic Con has been pretty dry in
terms of trailers to talk about so I
figured hey I'll watch valerian thousand
planets good enough commentary some
Valerians a movie written and directed
by Luc Besson he directed The Fifth
Element
halex cool also directed Lucy hopefully
this is a return to form it's based off
of a comic series ultimately these two
agents played by Dane DeHaan and Cara
Delevingne have to do a lot saying
there's a lot to do that has nothing
really to do with the main plot but
ultimately it's a few hundred years in
the future mankind of Earth has built a
Space Station that became kind of a hub
of many different civilizations coming
to earth and tearing their technology
and growing in the space station the
space station got so huge it had to be
sent away out into space and now it's
it's enormous
thanks to set it all from Mass Effect
but hey we humans made it and now
there's this energy source building in
the middle of it what's happened and
there's a really cute lizard hamster
thing that poos pearls I can't make that
up but what I liked about the movie is
visually is very imaginative it looks
great you saw the scene in the trailer
where he's running on air essentially
because there's a shield gun and he's
shooting it below his feet so he can run
on the shield across a precipice that's
really neat also the first mission
that's ultimately the introduction to
the characters it was a really cool
mission involving this marketplace that
isn't actually a marketplace in our
dimension you need to put on these
glasses so you can see the other
dimension and these gloves so you can
interact with it super cool stuff the
sci-fi geek in me was nerding out about
the tack the film phantom II was beating
my [ __ ] head against a wall about the
script and the characters there's so
many so many moments where the movie
tries to be funny and quickly who does
not mesh with the movie the characters
had no chemistry whatsoever cara
delevingne dane dehaan no you can tell
there's supposed to be a romance between
these two there's nothing there but no
han and Leia how it's like you I don't
like you but he actually secretly kind
of dude they wanted it to feel like that
but really it's you don't feel it near
the beginning of this movie there's this
dude he's just an extra and he has to do
with the first mission they're supposed
to do and her interaction with this
nobody character wasn't
times more convincing than any of the
interaction she had with Dane DeHaan up
to that point and a thousand times more
convincing than any interaction she
would have with him after that don't
know who the dude was but you sir should
have been her romantic interest and the
acting I know Dane DeHaan was a good
actor I have seen him be a good actor in
this movie which is I think he was just
miscast I don't know what the characters
like in the comic books but in this
movie he just kind of came across as
someone who had heard a Keanu Reeves
impersonation at one point was like I'm
gonna be a badass like him Keanu light
this woman I call him he's not good it
wasn't a role for him Cara Delevingne
man I don't know what I prefer her this
or this [ __ ] you know my stance on
Suicide Squad I have fun with it but
that [ __ ] was still ridiculous the look
was just so messy when I was talking
about there's so many plots in the movie
there's always a main plot and then what
we call there's a term for it it's
called subplot every movie has subplots
but the subplots usually tie in with the
main plot somehow or give you character
development somehow feed the story
somehow these subplots did none of that
it's almost like through these little
segments that were just filmed after the
movie was done they were like we only
have movie that's about an hour long we
can't do that we need to make more
so these entire little mini plots were
just filmed afterwards and snuck into
the movie just there we go here's
another one we'll sneak that into
another one BAM all right we have
ourselves a two-hour movie it's like a
video it's like an RPG game we're in the
RPG go to someone you're like hey I need
to find this item and the NPC's like
well I don't know who has it so you got
to go over there and talk to that guy
who might know and that guy has
information like yeah this other guy
might know but he might want you to do
something for him and the other guys
like yeah I can get it for you but you
have to infiltrate this guy doing a
banquet in his honor and be sure to push
the button at the right time
to salute and do jumping jacks when he
wants you to and after this three hour
long dissertation this side quest guys
like alright good job here's your item
and it's like that sometimes in RPGs it
works in it doesn't in a movie it
usually doesn't work guys in the end
valerian was pretty but it was a mess
the technology and the war was really
interesting would probably would have
been better suited elsewhere and it
looks like it is it's a mystery that has
no real mystery and all tension is lost
when everybody's trying to shoot down
these robots and they're killing
everybody but Dane DeHaan can one-hit
kill him with one bullet no tension
there I will say
probably not going to remember valerian
in t-minus one day yeah I've already
forgot my guys stuff Alerian have you
seen it what did you think about it
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always a good like we've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here it is me more
[Music]